we played a lot of pervs
James's evening we have just one more
it's called mommy's choice which one of
you will survive this year's purge the
soul of our country is as
the purge targets the poor and the
innocent the center is going to win
going to make real changes to it is a
night that is defining our country it's
time to do something about that senator
the purge has to come to an end you take
a lot of risks senator I have to I was
the only one in my family to survive
want me to apply for this position I
almost did something encouraging I some
years back I want this night time I want
men in all these rooms we got eyes and
ears on everything all right let's begin
this is your emergency broadcast system
announcing the commencement of the
annual purge at the siren all crime
including murder will be legal for 12
hours your government thanks you for
your participation
someone betrayed us this is not a drill
we are on our own
they were going right now survival
senator come with us Jenna understand
what's at stake
don't you do to help protect her here
they come
blessed the America for letting us purge
and cleanse our souls join me as we
eliminate
yabas fancy ah damn it for barking
stylist
the additional rubella some planets
targets